only on CBS mornings we're getting rare
access to a treasure Trove of evidence
stored at the FBI's archive inside the
bureau's headquarters in Washington from
the Unabomber's reconstructed cabin to
the boat where the Boston Marathon
bomber was caught the archive contains
artifacts from some of the country's
most notorious crimes and only a handful
of people have had access to this room
however the FBI allowed our Jeff begays
and our CBS News cameras to go inside
many of the artifacts in this secured
room have never been on display for the
public to see this is evidence some of
it from recent FBI cases some of it from
the 90s 80s even the 1920s and 30s let's
put the gloves on fragile to the touch
and treasure for FBI historian John Fox
these are the the parts of our past that
tell tell our story in a very different
way
the FBI story began in 1908 with the
establishment of the Bureau of
Investigation the mission and makeup of
the organization evolved and grew over
the next two decades by the 1920s and
30s the Great Depression and prohibition
spawn violent bank robbers and Killers
known as gangsters these gangsters were
like celebrities they were almost
celebrities yeah but J Edgar Hoover the
FBI's founding and longest serving
director used his Crackdown on gangsters
to make the FBI a household name Hoover
thought of them as Public Enemies that
people who needed to be you know dealt
with outlaws like John Dillinger and
Babyface Nelson were hunted down and
killed in shootouts with law enforcement
and later immortalized by their death
masks at that time law enforcement would
put the remains of some of these
gangsters on display for everybody to
see there was almost a public production
you know when Dillinger was shot outside
the Biograph Theater people were
actually dipping their handkerchiefs in
the blood for a Memento what do you
think when you look around this room
Paul Abate is the FBI's deputy director
I think it's the history of the FBI and
I think about the mission that we do the
work keep people safe protect the
country
and it's a reminder that we've
constantly have to stay focused on that
the chronicles of the FBI is also a
record of the shifting threats to the
country through the years and in the
last 40 years a new threat emerged
homegrown terrorism
downtown in 1995 the FBI launched one of
its most significant investigations to
date in the aftermath of the Oklahoma
City bombing this is a replica of the
rental truck used to house and transport
the explosives along with a model of the
Alfred P Murrah Federal Building it
shows the cutout of what parts of the
building were actually damaged all
evidence used to convict Mastermind
Timothy McVeigh who was executed by
lethal injection in June 2001 and the
Unabomber's cabin has been reconstructed
here inside the FBI it's where Ted
Kaczynski made bombs that killed three
people and injured nearly two dozen
others foreign
hunt for the 2013 Boston Marathon
bombers ended here in this bullet
riddled boat where zokar Tsarnaev was
found hiding how does this inform what
federal agents are doing today it's the
lessons learned
from the past
that includes failures mistakes and loss
he was my soul mate Joanne hatton's
husband Lenny was an FBI agent in New
York he was everything I could have ever
asked in a husband on 9 11 he raced to
the World Trade Center to help
Lenny Hatton died that day in the line
of duty and his passport is on display
in the archive the interesting thing
about the passport is that the
expiration date is actually September
11th
2001. wow this was given to us by his
wife to help us to tell the story of
agent Haddon and his career and his
sacrifices in filling the bureau's
missions it's near and dear to your
heart exactly Lenny hatton's story and
many others stored in this secure FBI
archive in the Hoover building remind
new and Veteran agents of the lives lost
and also the sacrifices made in pursuit
of the values on the bureau's seal
walking through here every day I think
about the victims in ensuring that we
prevent those types of harm from ever
happening again or CBS
ways in
gays well done Jeff the gays I love
anything that you can see behind the
scenes but the passport guys the
passport with the expiration date
Lenny's very spooky yeah
you realize how many of these stories
helped shape our Collective thought on
crime and punishment I mean we're
familiar with them because we've seen
them so many times over and over again
to walk through those Halls had to be
Eerie I like that the FBI cares enough
to have an official historian I hope he
gets a flash of the badge kick down
doors and confiscate things for history
a bad job yeah and I like that they
showed what worked and what didn't work
that's very important yeah no doubt
about it